BUT FIRST, OUR NEW NORMAL.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN HAS MADE IT
OFFICIAL.
NO MORE MR. MODERATE FROM
WILMINGTON.
OVER THE JULY 4TH WEEKEND, HE
PLEDGED TO FUNDAMENTALLY
TRANSFORM THE UNITED STATES.
TRANSLATION?
A GRAB BAG OF SQUAD APPROVED
MEASURES THAT BEGAN WITH MASSIVE
WEALTH COMPENSATION.
YOUR MONEY IS GOING TO BE USED
TO FUND A WAR ON OIL AND GAS.
REGULAR HARASSMENT OF
BUSINESSES.
A FLOOD OF FOREIGN WORKERS AND
REFUGEES.
GUN COMPENSATION FROM CITIZENS
ON BOGUS GROUNDS.
FREE HEALTH CARE INCLUDING
MEDICAL MARIJUANA FOR ILLEGALS.
GOVERNMENT HELD HEALTH CARE AND
OF COURSE, REPARATIONS.
THAT’S JUST A BIT.
AND OF COURSE, THIS IS ALL GOING
TO BE ACCOMPANIED WITH
RETRIBUTION FOR ANYONE AND
PUNISHMENT FOR ANYONE WHO
RESISTS.
SO THE DO G, THE FBI, A JETSONS
LIKE THE S GG ARE GOING TO BE
AGAINST HARDWORKING AMERICANS
WHO STILL BELIEVE IN FREEDOM.
WELL TODAY IN CALIFORNIA AND
NEW YORK, WE SEE EVIDENCE OF HOW
ALL OF AMERICA WILL OPERATE
UNDER A PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> I TRULY THINK THAT IF WE DO
THIS RIGHT WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT JUST DIG OUT
OF THIS CRISIS, BUT TO
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE FROM A
COUNTRY.
SO IT IS MORE FAIR, MORE JUST,
MORE EQUITABLE FOR EVERYBODY.
>> Laura: OH, YEAH.
MORE EQUITABLE?
ONFOR THE GREATER GOOD.
NOW THIS IS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE VIRUS WHICH IS
OVERWHELMINGLY SURVIVABLE FOR
MOST AMERICANS.
AND THESE DRACONIAN AND
ARBITRARY MOVES ARE ABOUT
POLITICS AND POWER.
NOW, UNDER DEMOCRATIC RULE, HOLD
ONTO YOUR WALLET, PROTECT YOUR
KIDS, AND GET READY TO LOSE
MONEY, YOUR FREEDOM, AND MOST OF
THE AMERICAN TRADITIONS THAT WE
ALL LOVE.
THESE LAST FOUR MONTHS, THE
ANGLE HAS BEEN DOING EVERYTHING
IN OUR POWER TO HELP GET AMERICA
BACK TO NORMAL.
MEANWHILE, THE DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR NEW ETIOLOGICAL SOULMATES
ON THE FAR LEFT -- THEY’VE BEEN
USING THIS TIME TO PLOT AND PLAN
ON HOW TO GET US TO A NEW
NORMAL.
NOW, I WARNED YOU ABOUT THAT
PHRASE IN EARLY APRIL.
I DETESTED IT THEN, AND WE HAVE
AMPLE REASON TO DETEST IT EVEN
MORE NOW.
SO TONIGHT, I DECIDED TO UNVEIL
OUR NEW NORMAL.
SO GOING FORWARD, THIS IS WHAT
WE SHOULD ALL BE ARGUING FOR.
A RETURN TO COMMON SENSE,
PRO-AMERICAN CONSERVATISM.
NOW NO OFFENSE TO 41 OR 43, WE
ARE NEVER GOING TO BE A BUSH
PARTY AGAIN.
I REALIZE THIS MAY UPSET THE
DOZENS OF WELL-FUNDED DRUM
HATING AMERICANS OUT THERE,
NEVERTHELESS.
OUR NEW NORMAL WILL BE ARDENTLY
ANTI-LEFTIST, AND A RELENTLESSLY
PRO-WORKER PARTY.
HAVE YOU NOTICED HOW MANY
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN HEADING
FOR THE HILLS WHEN THE GOING HAS
GOTTEN TOUGH IN RECENT MONTHS?
I CAN COUNT ON ONE MAYBE TWO
HANDS.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LEADING THE PUSH AGAINST BLM,
ANTIFA, EVEN CHINA.
AND NOW OF COURSE THE DEMOCRATS
ATTACKS ON AMERICAN INSTITUTIONS
INSTITUTIONS.
AFTER REVIEW, THEY PUBLISHED
THIS PIECE TODAY ABOUT HOW
LEGALIZING MARIJUANA WOULD BE A
GOOD THING TO DO NOW.
NOW, THIS IS A LEADING
CONSERVATIVE -- SOME NICE, SMART
PEOPLE THERE.
BUT THEY ARE SAME DRUGGIST DON’T
LIKE DRUGS ARE THE ANSWER?
OH, THAT WILL DO THE TRICK.
AGAIN, THIS IS WHAT OUR NEW
NORMAL WOULD LOOK LIKE.
NUMBER ONE, SUPPORTING ONLY
THOSE WHO FIGHT TO SAVE AMERICA.
SO BEFORE YOU GIVE A DIME TO A
CONSERVATIVE GROUP OR A
THINK TANK OR A CANDIDATE, OR A
CAMPAIGN, ASK YOURSELF -- WHERE
WERE THEY WHEN WE NEEDED THEM?
IF THE ANSWER IS THEY SET ON THE
SIDELINES AND SPENT THEIR TIME
CRITICIZING THE PRESIDENT AND
HELPING BIDEN, THEY SHOULD HAVE
NO FUTURE IN REPUBLICAN
POLITICS.
NUMBER TWO, PRESERVING OUR
HISTORY, OUR DECK DECLARATION, A
CONSTITUTION.
WE WILL PROBABLY PROTECT OUR
NATIONAL HOLIDAYS AND OUR
MONUMENTS AND SOME OF THE NAMES
OF STATES AND CITIES -- WE WILL
GET TO THAT IN A MOMENT.
AND GET ON AN EFFORT TO EDUCATE
AMERICA ON THE GREATNESS OF OUR
FOUNDERS AND KEEP PROGRESS.
CONTRIBUTIONS OF ALL RACES AND
CREEDS WILL BE CELEBRATED AND
APPRECIATED.
NUMBER THREE, NO MORE LOCKDOWNS.
VIRUSES ARE A FACT OF LIFE.
AND IT’S VERY SAD.
AND SOMETIMES, AS WITH COVID-19,
THERE WILL BE AWFUL TRAGIC
RESULTS.
WE NEED TO TRY TO FIND
TREATMENTS, BUT TRAMPLING ON OUR
BASIC RIGHTS AND WRECKING
BUSINESSES, RUINING LIVELIHOODS,
BANKRUPTING OUR COUNTRY, IS
SIMPLY NO LONGER AN OPTION.
EVEN DR. FAUCI HAD TO ADMIT A
VACCINE MAY NEVER COME.
NUMBER FOUR, KIDS NEED TO STAY
IN SCHOOL.
TEACHERS ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
THEY ARE JUST LIKE FIREFIGHTERS
AND POLICEMEN THAT WAY.
THEY NEED TO BE ON THE JOB.
A NEW GERMAN STUDY OUT TODAY
CONFIRMS WHAT WE KNEW FROM
ICELAND’S EXPERIENCE.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT KIDS
SPREAD COVID IN SCHOOL.
IF THE ANTISCIENCE CROWD
CLAIMING TO BE THE SCIENCE CROWD
FROM CALIFORNIA TO OREGON HAVE
ANNOUNCED THEY ARE GOING TO HOLD
NO IN PERSON EDUCATION FOR KIDS
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE THAT.
THE IDIOTIC MODIFIED SCHEDULE OF
NEW YORK AND PLACES LIKE
VIRGINIA ARE A TOTAL NIGHTMARE
AS WELL.
THIS WILL BE CATASTROPHIC FOR
PARENTS AND KIDS.
TO START MAKING NOISE ON THAT.
NUMBER FIVE, NO TWO ENDLESS
EDICTS.
YES TO ACTUAL LAWS.
GOVERNORS HAVE BEEN SLAPPED DOWN
BY STATE COURTS FOR OVERSTEPPING
THEIR AUTHORITY DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
SO THIS IS BEEN MY POINT.
IF MASKS AND SOCIAL DISTANCING
ARE REALLY THE ONLY ANSWER WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW, THEN WHY DIDN’T
BIDEN GET OUT OF THE BASEMENT
AND PUSH NANCY PELOSI TO COME
BACK INTO SESSION AND PASS A LAW
REQUIRING THEM?
WELL, I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
THEY LOVE UNACCOUNTABLE POWER.
THEY’RE NOT SURE THEY WILL WIN
IN COURT IF CHALLENGED.
NUMBER SIX, HANDS OFF OUR PLACES
OF WORSHIP.
WE REJECT THAT MANY STATE
GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE RIGHT UNDER
THE U.S. CONSTITUTION TO STOP US
FROM GOING TO PRACTICE OUR FAITH
AND OUR RELIGIOUS COMMUNITIES.
FREEDOM OF WORSHIP AS IT
ESSENTIAL TO MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS.
NOW, CATHOLIC BISHOPS SPENT AS
MUCH EFFORT DEFENDING THEIR
PARISHES AS THEY SPENT DEFENDING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, WE MAY HAVE
ALREADY WON ON THIS ISSUE.
NUMBER SEVEN, NO CODDLING OF
CRIMINALS.
NEW YORK AND CHICAGO HAVE SEEN A
HEINOUS RISE IN MURDERS AND
ROBBERY SINCE THE D FUND THE
POLICE EFFORT BEGAN.
THE POLICY THE LEFTIST DEMANDS
IS OUR NEW NORMAL.
BUT AOC WASN’T A-OK TRYING TO
EXPLAIN THE RECENT VIOLENT CRIME
SEARCH.
>> MAYBE THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE AREN’T PAYING
THEIR RENT AND ARE SCARED TO PAY
THE RENT.
THEY ARE PUT IN A POSITION WHERE
THEY EITHER NEED TO SHOPLIFT
SOME BREAD OR GO HUNGRY THAT
NIGHT.
>> Laura: I MUST ADMIT ALL THE
BREAD THEFTS THAT WERE
HAPPENING.
LOOTERS WHO DESTROYED THE CIVIL
RIGHTS OF OTHERS WHO SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED, NOT RELEASED BACK
ONTO THE STREET.
SAME SHOULD APPLY TO POLICE.
NUMBER EIGHT, NEW INDUSTRIAL
POLICIES CALLED "MADE IN THE
USA."
40 YEARS IN WASHINGTON OF BIDEN
TELLS US THAT WHOLE THING WAS A
LIE.
OUR ECONOMIC POLICY SHOULD MAKE
IT EASIER TO DO BUSINESS HERE.
ALL ESSENTIAL MEDICINE SUPPLY
CHAINS NEED TO BE BROUGHT BACK
HOME PUT PERIOD.
NUMBER NINE, CALL OUT COMPANIES.
THE NBA AND SPORTS MEDIA ARE A
CASE STUDY IN THIS VERY TYPE OF
HYPOCRISY.
IT’S WORTH REMEMBERING THAT THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
BRUTALIZE AS MUSLIMS AS A MATTER
OF STATE POLICY.
SPORTS MEDIA HAVE FALLEN ALL
OVER THEMSELVES TO SUPPORT THE
POLITICAL MOVEMENT OF BLM, BUT
THE BRUTALITY OF CHINA: THEY
UTTERLY IGNORE.
NO LeBRON JAMES’ DEAL WITH
NIKE IS REPORTEDLY WORTH
$1 BILLION.
WELL, NIKE RAKED IN 6 BILLION
FROM CHINA LAST YEAR.
NO WONDER IT LeBRON INCENSED
BY THE HONG KONG TWEET LAST
FALL.
THE KING OF BEIJING, THAT HAS A
NICE RING TO IT.
NUMBER TEN, CANCEL THAT CANCEL
CULTURE.
WHEN THEY SEEK TO DESTROY PEOPLE
OR COMPANIES JUST BECAUSE THEY
DISAGREE ON POLITICS WE WILL
ANSWER THEM WITH LAWSUITS AND BY
BUY CUTS.
>> THERE ARE THOSE WHO ARE BORN
TO LOVE AND TO BUILD AND OTHERS
TO HATE AND DESTROY.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, THERE IS A
MOVEMENT OF HATRED AND
DESTRUCTION.
>> Laura: THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO APOLOGIZE FOR STANDING NEXT
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> , NO.
>> Laura: AND FINALLY, D FUND
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
IT’S TIME TO STOP SENDING OUR
TAX DOLLARS TO PROFESSORS AN END
ADMINISTRATORS WHO TEACH
STUDENTS TO HATE AMERICA.
IF I WERE IN CONGRESS I WOULD
HOLD HEARINGS AND I WOULD START
ASKING THESE COLLEGE PRESIDENTS
THAT TAKE FEDERAL MONEY, HOW
MANY CONSERVATIVES DO YOU HAVE
IN YOUR FACULTY?
WHAT’S THE RATIO OF CONSERVATIVE
TO LIBERAL COMMENCEMENT
SPEAKERS?
DO ANY OF YOUR FACULTY MEMBERS
HATE THE COUNTRY?
DO YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE THAT
THEY DO?
DO YOU EVER CONSIDER HIRING
AMERICANS WHO DON’T HATE THE
COUNTRY:?
PRECISELY THE TYPE OF NEW NORMAL
BUT TRUMP RAN ON IN 2016.
HE’S MADE GREAT PROCESS AND ALL
THE ITEMS THAT ME AND HANNITY
WERE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER.
THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN COMFORTABLE
WITH THIS POLICY AND SOME ARE
ANXIOUS TO GET BACK TO THE GOOD
OLD DAYS OF, YOU KNOW, PERPETUAL
INTERNATIONALISM AND
INTERVENTIONALLISM.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
WHILE OTHERS WILL HAVE YOU
LOCKED DOWN INDEFINITELY, TRUMP
HAS YOU FIGHTING FOR YOUR RIGHT
TO PURSUE YOUR OWN HAPPINESS.
HE TRUSTS YOU TO MANAGE YOUR OWN
RISK AS WE ALL DO EVERY DAY.
AND IF HE IS ON NEXT YEAR,
DEMOCRATS LED BY JOE, THEY ARE
GOING TO RUN ROUGHSHOD OVER
EVERYTHING YOU AND I HAVE WORKED
FOR.
THAT’S THE ONLY NEW NORMAL WE
ARE GOING TO PERMIT.
AND ANYONE LOOKING CLOSELY AT
BIDEN KNOWS THE ONLY NEW THING